here is a native New Yorker who spent
more than 30 years in the industry was a
golf course superintendent before
returning to grad school in 1986 he was
recognized in 2001 by golf week magazine
is one of the 40 most influential people
in the game of golf under the age of 40
shared with Tiger Woods and Jack
Nicklaus he's an international expert in
Gulf and sports turf management
published hundreds of articles has
traveled around the world lecturing on
environmentally responsible and
sustainable turf grass management less
reliance on fertilizer and pesticide
he's appeared on CNN ESPN PBS the Golf
Channel and just in numerous magazines
USA began New York Times Wall Street
Journal he's been a visiting professor
at the Swedish agricultural university
and
does leave turf consultant for New York
Yankees Green Bay Packers the Lincoln
Center for Performing Arts so he's got
long list in addition to his career
inter crank is married in the father of
three children a triathlete member of
his local school board hospice volunteer
Little League coach and alpaca farmer
thanks for joining us I think you're
going to see my idea might be wondering
at this point what's the link between
living sculpture and art and grass and
he will be showing you they'll be no
doubt about that yeah that's the first
time I've had to listen to that I used
to be really short my wife was nudging
me that I should write on there but then
there's the risk of sounding like a nut
ball as Marsha said thanks to Marcia and
Craig and all the people that work to
put this on max downstairs I'm really
thrilled to be here and i have to tell
you spending most of my life as kind of
a functional turf person this has been a
real guys I think we started this four
or five videos because if I lose you
me in the order culture and what I want
I want to start out with the end and the
end is that the best part about my
involvement in all this stuff has been
how it stretched me I love you know I
was a golf course superintendent a big
golfer I'm really just a grass guy I've
spent most of my life was born and
raised in the fort of section of the
bronx oh I don't have a lot of you know
Gloria's grass stories piece up beyond
pushing a lawn mower and trying to get
out to a golf course for some open space
so a lot of my grassed up both in golf
and sports filter strips and functional
things and now alpaca passengers has
been very functional and what I've liked
about this work is that it's really kind
of stretched me a lot and and I think
that's one of the great things that
comes out of doing this work and that's
why i was happy of course honored to be
able to give the opening talk because i
think what you're going to experience
today is is is is this stretching I mean
there's a you get there is a pile of
dirt and a load of grass and next thing
you know it's something and so I look
forward to seeing I wish I hope I get to
be there to see your faces at the very
end because I think as much as it from
longwood that's really the cool thing
about this work and I hope that we can
just get you started with some ideas to
stretch you beyond what you do today so
so we'll see a lot of these kinds of
pictures this is actually a Robeson near
the London Bridge this was a promotion
for a TV program in
in the UK with a sculptured swimmer and
mounded grass to look like water we'll
look at this a little more closely as we
get into the form so we've titled this
the thrill of the grass and craig kramer
gave me one of these short stories from
WP Kinsella which is the title of his
story and the story is about a guy who
rosenstiel side from a field and takes
it home so it's really kind of
fascinating story this is a mile in and
he did them this is a nuts about a year
him and these are just these earth
mounds that she's done they're really
easy to do and very as as most of her
work very symbolic and of course what
what we're trying to do is that what I'm
trying to talk to you about and get you
inspired about is using earth as a
canvas which is not unique to us here
but I think with marshes leadership
really I think have done some really
cool things and of course we can be
fairly whimsical this is an artist down
in Texas who her lawn was dormant
Bermuda grass or dormant st. Augustine
grass whatever the heck that crab grass
is your drama down there Felder it looks
much better with polka dots great honor
and then of course there's the
functional aspect and that's where I
want to start this is what's been the
most comfortable for me grass is
function this is in between the strips
on this tram we're obviously there's
pavement aggressive and we've been doing
a lot of work with Nina basak looking at
the stroke this structural soil she
developed that they can grow street
trees on we're now using it to grow
grass on and thinking about starting to
replace these four acre Walmart more
parking lots with grass parking lots
that can then filter a lot of the
pollutants that would come
we're nuts about grass in this country
and I'm sure you know that just in New
York State alone we have about three and
a half million acres of turf that we
would call turf managed grass and we
spend about five billion dollars a year
in New York State about 75 to 80 billion
nationally is spent managing grass so
we're absolutely nutty about grass and
you know I I think i spent most of my
career trying to figure out how to help
us not be so nutty but the fact is most
of that money spent by homeowners in and
around their laws so some people go to
extremes take the lawn out pile up some
gravel and of course then you don't want
a hot summer day you're going to feel
fairly more matter of fact you may see
one of the more ridiculous things in
your life walking outside today if you
venture out at all if on this side of
campus where we have some of our sports
fields there's a synthetic turf field
hockey field plastic grass that we water
four times a day with what can only be
described as a fire hose sprinkler to
cool it off because it's so warm to play
on that the athletes can't stay on a
very long lessons unless it's cool now
functionally obviously this is a loss
Matt come out of the shower step on that
that's actually not such a bad deal and
of course a lot of these things you can
buy or do yourself now back to the
functional part I spend a lot of my time
working in a fairly you know with school
districts regular folk trying to have
decent grass for the safety of their
athletes and then we get to talk about
how even in the professional level
managing turf for these athletes to
ensure their safety maximize their
performance and
their safety is really critical this was
of course a game that the Pittsburgh
Steelers played a number of years ago
when they brought in grass and Sun and
over an existing field three inches of
rainfall in and turned into a muddy mess
where the athletes weren't safe at all
so we spent a lot of time trying to help
clubs and athletes have a safe service
to play now there is an aesthetic part
to what we do it looks you know what you
do for looks and this is actually one of
our research experiments where we're
looking at different forms of iron iron
is one of the really critical nutrients
for color in a green a green plant
because it's involved in the chlorophyll
molecule so if you really want to do
something crazy on your lawn and don't
want to fertilize it we've done some
work looking at using iron as opposed to
fertilizers that might contaminate water
quality we found an iron is a really
easy way to get green grass without
having to get it to grow so much this is
something we were experimenting now of
course golf courses we one could find
some part in this little practice
facility that was built and you start to
see some of the striping Faxon the
interaction with the bunkers at
different heights of khat you've got a
green up cutting surface cut at about a
tenth of an inch a fairway cut at about
a third of an inch and then you've got
grass around the bunkers that are
probably cut at about two or three
inches so sometimes just different
heights can give you a very different
look this is the flower hole at the
Stevens Point country club in central
Wisconsin
or I used to work before I came back to
Cornell they changed this floral display
three times ear of course I'm sure all
you are looking at flowers I'm always of
course looking at the grass but the
contrast here between the colors in the
you know the deep green of the grass and
the various colors of the flowers they
change this display three times a year
it takes about 14 employees the better
part of 40 hours to change the floral
displays here's one of my favorite
pictures this is fanden dunes or Pacific
News golf course right along the south
western Oregon coast it's a fairly new
golf course and what I love is how grass
kind of brings it out the subtle
wrinkles in the earth here there was
very little done when this golf course
was built and designed by Cornell along
tom doak this is a very minimalist golf
course very little was done here you can
see they're just kind of threw some sand
in places this is just a beautiful piece
of land that they planted some grass
over the top and there's very little
management done out there to keep this a
playable service of course you can get
ridiculous with this and some people
like off so much they do it in their
office nothing living there and then
there's of course the occasional fool
decisive grass is entire inside of the
house and we're sucking the fumes you
can imagine what he's so happy and then
there's a functional aspect of room so
we have a room inside and here is a room
at the state fair the New York State
Fair last year there was a living
sculpture demonstration done there where
they build a couple of sitting chairs a
little love see a couch which you will
be involved in working on
today and one of the things that we're
constantly you know obviously it looks
good right now you're going to get to do
something today that might help it
sustain itself sometimes getting these
things watered and keeping them healthy
is a little tricky so we've been
figuring out ways of doing that in a
sustainable fashion I expect to work in
some fairly ridiculous environments this
is a project I've been working on for
the last five years associated with the
65th Street renovations for Lincoln
Center the lincoln center development
project this is the conceptual drawing
that they started with about five years
ago and this is what it looked like last
week this is the Juilliard School right
here this is the new addition to the
Juilliard School I was totally home and
this is a 25 million dollar which is
going to be a park on top of a
restaurant on 60 50 so pretty soon
you'll get to see this in living color
if you live down a Manhattan or longer
down that way this is at kew gardens
again functionally grass can be a great
thing for bleachers maybe for stepping
stones maybe for just functionally
having it in your backyard for stairs of
the downer just giving you that
cascading effect and make transition to
using grass for forms this is a
Dartmouth College they've got Dartmouth
in New Hampshire I can tell you that one
of the things that guys like me struggle
with is architects who sit there drawing
a piece of paper and saying oh is now
look really cool and then somebody's got
to take care of it the poor guys got you
know I have a sprinkler that he has here
too you know everybody wants it green
and he's got to climb up here to trim
this tip
and because you can't really get up
there with anything so these do create
unique problems that students love them
but they are weak maintenance situation
now for reform perspective it can be
fairly simple these are little indoor
grass planters that you can get on the
web just to head out in your in your
house the cheetah professor maybe this
is where your kids will start you can
use the little plant seeds that they
send you or you can use grass seed just
as well and here's the swimmer again
just you know a matter of mounting up
some grass and making it look like the
swimmers making its way through and you
can see how intricate this is this
obviously the structure is though one of
the highlights here but you can see the
interaction with his face and the grass
there and the mounds looking where his
hands are going in it's just really a
fascinating display again one of the
things about some of this artwork is it
doesn't stay around long you do it looks
really cool and then they take it away
and all those are the pictures there's
my own project this is the law snake
this is from that turf works book by
Paul Cooper who was here a number of
years ago it was very pleasant meeting
him and he took some of these scans
right out of his book again nothing more
than some stone and one of the tricks we
use for loss is mixing it with in a
blender with buttermilk take Moss put in
a blender mix it up a buttermilk and
just smear it on and you know grow some
rocks long because it gets a little bit
of moisture it usually will grow freely
well some really interesting structures
that you can do with longer grass as
well as planting grass over
almost like a Tokyo now one of the
things that I've liked about this is you
know when you go start looking around
for these things you see how people use
graphs you know to make a statement and
this is at the University of Illinois
they planted these boxes to represent
the age child fatality statistics
there's three thousand blades of grass
in a square foot and send to depth to
recognize the 60,000 people per year
under the age of 12 who died of acres so
they use just having the grass out there
as a way of honoring that and then just
odd forms of artwork inside a structure
that is basically extra minute from a
ceiling with crow lights and sod laid
over the top of it push again you can
use plastic grass and this is an example
of that where they use some living plant
material for the bucket but the carpet
itself here is synthetic turf this is
the London Museum of Art you can see the
guy watering it it's basically just a
big pile of grass and it's really
fascinating at night when I was there it
was really really amazing this is a
chapel in Czechoslovakia and I'm tonight
so I'll get in the Czech Republic
someone sent me this one Craig sends me
a lot of these but you can see they put
grass on the outside as well as on the
inside and you can see it growing here
and and basically it's the kind of thing
that they do and then strip off and
every year we'll redo it
completely recycle all the things that
are used to do it but the structure
itself is cemented and of course here's
a little topiary thing with some grass
on it and of course now you can start
again again getting into the whimsical a
little bit the giraffe on the lawn
people like putting things on their
lawns then we get into the whole animal
range and you'll meet one of our
favorite animal construction people
Danielle today this is again have that
turf works book again if you can't have
grass a lie there's a synthetic version
of the bowl and here she is one I think
really one of our stars I remember when
she was taking marshes class she showed
up but this was part of one of her art
of horticulture projects she shows up in
my office and I'm going to talk about
doing this and she has this tray with
her and on the tray are about seven
different farm animals and she's got a
count-out [ __ ] chicken goat big sheep
she's like this is what I want to do
okay I think we got to do one let's try
to do one and I think it was really
really epitomized kind of the energy
that she's brought to doing this and so
this is again a shaped pile of soil and
she built this head with chicken wire
and stuffed it with hay and there's
these two by fours that are attaching it
into the soil pile and i can tell you of
all the graduation of the 15 or 16
graduation weekends i've been a part of
I've never seen so many people gathered
around a single thing in my entire
career here everybody wanted their
picture taken on graduation weekend in
front of Morrison Hall and the calf
doesn't have a name is it Daisy misty
and then some water Laura Danielle's
work now what was fascinating about this
piece of project is is it evolved it
started out as green grass shape letters
for the college of agricultural and life
sciences right cows right out on the
quad but then as it started to die and
go dormant she spray painted it black
and white so it had a whole nother life
after it was still living now here's
this is how simple this is this was
Marsh's from a few years ago one of her
art of horticultural projects with a
bunch of students and we had a couple of
hours to do it my staff may give us a
pile of dirt and that's what you'll
start out with today if you're doing
this particular project and then we get
out there we get all kinds of people
running side cutters I am supervising
and the idea was to create this walk
path around this mound and that's what
it looked like when we were done we cut
this off from an adjacent area we used
water to kind of tamp down the path area
and then laid some sod over the top and
there's the class of the very end this
is the year the following year the class
wanted to try something different so
I've never started with a now the dirt
we made stairs and at the top they
planted a door which I have to tell you
that the Cornell golf courses right over
here the eighth hole and there was an
enormous amount of interest matter of
fact when you come over the hill on the
80 and you see this all you can actually
see is the door and you know its
authority and so this was really quite a
thing until a 50 mile an hour wind came
and took the doorway so it has not the
door is all over there but the mound is
still there now this is marshes project
at Longwood Gardens that basically again
just another form of soil and grass
there was a
mold made to shape the pattern yes and I
just want to Alex lovallo there is
really he has done the design for this
and work project with me is also one of
the workshop yeah and you'll see Alex
again in another picture here how long
did this live down a week a week but
it's all be usable ok now how about
furniture this is some of what you're
going to do nice little bed here in a
chair in the middle of Paris hello
little lawn chair sitting there you can
see the size of it relative to things
around it's a fairly large chair and you
can do this in your yard of all kinds of
lawn furniture you can actually be
fairly sophisticated about it or you can
just take a chaise lounge and place them
play some grass over the top of it nice
and easy some variations of sod sofas
here's a nice one integrated into a
garden you can buy a cardboard structure
fill it up with soil plant some grass
over the top and that's available on
inhabit calm fairly easy to do something
that you can do in your own backyard
some whimsical things these foam grass
blades that we found a little saw end
table here another bed it with some
sheets installed really fairly inviting
I think and then or something simple
this is one of our very first efforts
that Alex built this is one of the art
of horticulture students fairly simple
here's how it started out with the bear
area a pile of compost that the Cornell
Browns people brought over Alex started
to shape it and then you've got a side
couch so fairly easy to do you can one
of the things that we've seen useful is
maybe just a hand trim
are you sick but you don't have to mow
it you can mow it mowing encourages it
to spread and get thicker but this was
so small it could be done by hand fairly
easy yeah I would recommend that or we
have some battery-operated shears that I
used to it I don't like the idea of a
string trimmer because they're very
difficult to keep level and what happens
if you've ever worked on it really pulls
it into the ground and then you've got
these brown half moods all over the
structure now this is a project that
Marcia's husband did in one of his old
cams and here's Alex so you'll see today
again you know my Tom Watson said over
the weekend a bunch of old fogies right
getting around piling up some dirt
shaping it with a little bit of moisture
laying some grass over the top and lo
and behold you've got a couch to sit on
how long did that can you use grass seed
or does it have to be all rolled out
yeah very good question um you can use
grass seed but then of course you're
waiting but I would recommend on some of
these slopes that if you did that that
you use some kind of erosion that
because of the steepness of the slope
even gently watering it is going to
cause some erosion but you can there's
lots of erosion tight match you can use
or you know even at the garden center
they sell look that seed mulch stuff you
can just pack that on like a mud pack if
you don't want to use aside now you can
cut side from one part of your yard and
that's what we did out of the out of our
research center we did it with your
students we just cut it from one place
and put it in another place another
question sorry everything we're
community colleges
um some of them like the there was one
where there are some you know little
pieces of wood or metal just to kind of
hold things together but generally it's
just piles and sorted and once the grass
gets stabilized it really holds it
together from this is a project at alexs
stared down at the youth bureau in honor
of Marsha and her husband Scott and
again this is a nice integration of
stonework with a little bit of couch
this is right in our little downtown t
Burke our little this is our little
village where we live in just a link a
little bit and again just a pile of soil
a couple rocks at the end you try time
up here didn't you had network it didn't
work going it gets too much love this
couch we think the kids love this little
thing and then some of our students have
done some lawn furniture this is nothing
more than a flat of grow mix put in a
greenhouse with tons of rye grass seed
and you make a little cushion and you
pull it out of the flag you put it on
top of the chair lawn chair how about an
entire bar bad deal this is one of
Marsha students horse's name Zach yeah
he was a baby active kid this is just a
bunch of grass growing on burlap that we
slapped on top of us structure he made
on wheels and there's his little tiki
bar okay so what about mowing patterns
and you're going to see you're going to
have a little workshop about this this
is probably the easiest of all things to
do because it's simply a matter of
mowing the grass in different directions
or rolling the grass or in some cases
spritzing it with a little water there
was a actually did incorporate the
picture
but if you watch the major league
baseball all-star game which it doesn't
look like many of you would actually
turn the major league baseball all-star
game on but if you did you would have
seen the st. Louis if I didn't think it
was and in the outfield they had in the
grass and image of the Gateway Arch and
underneath it an image burned into the
grass of the state of them the state
capital of missouri and they had these
little windows in there is talking to
the groundskeeper maybe a month or so
ago and he just gets a little water
spread sir spritz the water into these
squares max the grass down so it's
folded in one direction different from
the way the grass is molding and you get
nice and simple at Yankee Stadium that's
the way we like it they're much more
interested in winning baseball games and
having fancy patterns on the grass but
Dave melon wrote a wonderful book called
picture-perfect if you're interested in
this it's really an interesting little
we very simple take care of grass very
simply I knew Dave when he was the
groundskeeper at milwaukee county
stadium where the brewers used to play
and he was the one that originally
started a lot of this craze that's going
on in the turf industry with regard to
blowing patterns dave is now the
groundskeeper for the Boston Red Sox at
Fenway Park so we have that we have
sometimes crowns managers who maybe have
an acid flashback or something
you can imagine what the athletes and of
course if you're sitting on the other
side that field it looks completely
different here's the starburst again at
County Stadium this was popular there at
the shea stadium for a while before they
closed up this is Frontier field in
rochester in preparation for the
triple-a all-star game a few years ago
again nothing more than just mowing the
patterns in different directions this is
rosenblatt stadium home of the College
World Series with some baseball's on it
gets fairly sophisticated you can get
fairly sophisticated or fairly simple
this is corey Mellors drawing for her
dad dad can you do this and he went out
that county stadium now sometimes people
do some really goofy things by accident
this was a person in central Wisconsin
who was very worried about fertilizer
running off their long so her idea was
put the fertilizer to drop spreader open
it all the way up run around the lawn
and put the water on really quick
because then it'll all get even right
and just put it down there and water it
runs off so much that along it even we
got a call from this person who thought
this was a lull running around the yard
so you can do these kinds of things just
with a little bit of fertilizer because
you can see
the fertilizer doesn't move very far
from where you put it down but again it
doesn't have to be very complicated
here's a very simple pattern just mowing
crop circles if you've ever read Michael
Poland's work particularly in second
nature where he has this chapter called
y mo he talks about mowing crop circles
in as long and most people can do this
fairly easily really the only
requirement is is to have some sort of a
roller or a tire on your boat very
simple little pattern here in a
community leaving an area unload this is
getting more popular now as we're
starting to realize the carbon emission
problem from our lawn mowers we've gone
have been on a real push over the last
several years now to try to get people
to reduce the number of times that
they're mowing their lawns recognizing
number one lawns are trapping car right
green plants are trapping carpet and
that's really good taking the carbon
dioxide out of the atmosphere but it
seems a little odd that we're also
burning a fair amount of carbon to keep
the loan so we're constantly working on
ways of being more sustainable keeping
the term healthy enough so then it can
continue to track carbon obviously when
it's grounded not growing it's not
trapping much carpet but at the same
time not going crazy with the mowing
strategies so that we're burning so much
car here's one that i found this
electric strike and a golf course very
you can see sometimes you can get hard
work deterrent you have absolutely no
that you have no reason you were
involved in at all other than
there to take a picture here's that
artist in Texas again as the long
started to green up she liked the idea
maybe just purple polka dot here she is
really just a fascinating oh yeah I
personally think this would be really
cool to live next to something like this
is regular spray paint it's just uh it's
just they make they make athletic field
market panel you can put on the grass
doesn't kill the grass as well you know
relatively of animal I wouldn't say it's
good for the environment but it
certainly is titanium dioxide oftentimes
it wouldn't be something I want to
necessarily dispersed but certainly it's
the great most of it degrades well on
the brown grass it would last a fairly
long time because it's not growing on
the green grass here i would say at
least three weeks to a month it grows on
you mow it blows up later right no it
sticks to the grass plants fairly well
it sticks to the grass plants very well
now how about some flyovers these are
just a little bit of a stretch for
calling it turf right but it's really
some fascinating things this is some
muck soil in japan where you can tell
where they plow a little and left some
of the crop but some of this stuff is
actually a me this is actually from L&L
gala this is right down here in the
Catskills and you've got no know if you
can see them you can see some of the
hang gliders people hang on over these
things some really cool stuff here's one
of the hang gliders a promotion for the
American Museum of Natural History
Statue of Liberty again you know not
really of course this is really just a
hey field that was well but you could do
the same thing with a law if you wanted
to do it from your bedroom you could you
know get a stencil
and Mark it out with flags and go out
there and cut some of it law and you
could do the same thing there here's my
favorite Sarah America somebody that
would be the trouble of doing Sheriff
Palin in the middle of the middle of a
so and this is one that we did this is a
marsh at one of Marcia's classes this is
our turf research facility Marcia did a
one credit course where they worked on
designing this thing for Mother's Day
and then they were flying mothers for
free in planes over to see and so she
actually produced a video that I think
you can get on her website you think
they made a video a DVD of the
production of this and you know sort of
its mulch and you have hay bales and
some of this stuff here is nothing more
than black plastic that they put over
the top to ET late the grass so it gets
bleached you know if you just exclude
light from grass it gets white or yellow
depending on how long and eventually
doing it I'll get prachy but if you just
leave it on for a little while basically
what you're looking at is light starve
grass so you could do all kinds of
things with different shades of green
and maybe mulches and there's some hay
bales here this was an area that she
killed out and they get a maypole or
something you think it's a maple
building this is along the coast of
oregon they hit a little confident ulm
app here with grass around it but that's
kind of interesting how about grass you
can wear right Neiman Marcus did a big
thing a few years ago on garden attire
made some grass shoes again you know
nothing more than you know mat onto
burlap stapled on to a shoe this is
again a large sheet of burlap if you can
see here again use a black plastic to
give that leopard effect by doing a
light at school
excluding light from the grass so you
get that kind of leopard effect on the
grass coat itself here's the garden
party add that Neiman Marcus was running
again had pocketbook shoes how about
jewelry this is one of my favorites that
Craig sent me you can here's his little
time to making jewelry spritz in his
little bit of grass making a fashion
statement here with a little tough to
grass on the end or brass knuckles
instead of brass knuckles now here's
what you need to do these things burlap
cheap grass seed and peat moss and you
can make a bag this is one of our
students fed grass pocketbook or some
grass dress how long would that stay
green if you put miracle grow on it I
bet you if you spread it with
miracle-gro once a week and mowed it I'm
sure we live several months if you gave
it enough hanging out on them this piece
of you put on the clothes line when it's
raining right better pull the clothes in
from the littles I put it out there when
it's raining there's no sort yes I was
over Berlin a little bit of people's we
grow side I'll be onyx that mean this is
not I mean yeah this is really cool but
we've been doing this for the last 20
years on black plastic accelerated side
production is very popular in Europe
they'll use you know compost and about
an eighth of an inch throw a ton of
grass on it make a grass back and use it
for gold mouths or other areas that
we're out really quickly on the cross
fields of soccer fields yeah not if
you're prepared to give it water and
nutrients over the top you ever seen it
growing the cracks in the sidewalk
see how easy my accountants so how about
some devices these are somewhat critical
this is that this is whimsical when it's
actually a reality what a hundred and
twelve million dollars will buy you this
is the university of phoenix stadium a
view outside of phoenix arizona where
they often play the super bowl a
national championship and they wanted to
be able to have a grass field inside now
i was involved in 1994 at the pontiac
silverdome project when i was working at
Michigan State University where we
developed an indoor grass system to play
the World Cup when the world cup soccer
was here in 1994 and basically what we
found is you can really grasp can't live
in these dog stadiums for more than 30
days so we've had that's why you see a
lot of retractable dome stages they got
an Arizona in Seattle walkies got one
where the dome houston weather weather
you know you open the dome for the grass
and then you close it so that the
creatures can be comfortable when
they're in there well they decided an
alternative to doing that in Phoenix is
to slide the field in and there you go
bill takes about an hour and 40 minutes
it's on this massive structure here on
railroad tracks takes about an hour and
40 minutes to move in and matter so when
they're not using it it sits outside and
basking in the Sun with a little bit of
water and when they want it they roll it
in okay so next time you watch a game in
Arizona that's what you get of course
these are good uses for lawn mowers the
redneck riding mower
that grass bike really nice with a grass
jacket there the integration of apparel
and functional travel the [ __ ] hit the
grass bug the grass Accord somebody
that's probably smoking some of the
grass the ocean a little bit of grass
dashboard how about a grasp go crash
board instead of a dashboard grass on
the seats dude how about this take your
shoes off walk on grass all day and then
there's one of the more interesting
things we tried this past year is the
use of grass as a film this is some work
that was done a number of years ago
where they took a grass canvas literally
grew it on burlap which is what we did
and then made it dark and then exposed
the this picture here and then shot the
picture on the grass so that it would
ultimately develop the picture right
because you have different shades of
light over the top of the grass and that
the picture itself would develop over
time this is again a grass canvas with a
overhead projector and a plexi get
Plexiglas and a water dripping down and
so you have stripes on the pan and water
dripping in and you could see it on the
grass candies here are some pictures
again big grass canvas with a picture
shown on it saying here this is how it
look one look that was developed and
here's the one more she did in the
library last year this is two sheets of
burlap with rye grass planted on it half
to some two-by-fours put together you
can see the wood that's suspending it
and then we took a projector computer
image
and shown Gandhi on it made his big
black pot I don't have a lot of pictures
on it I should have it but I can tell
you it was the talk of the campus for
about a two week period because it had a
little black hole I have these little
holes drilled in this big black draped
display that was plentiful how wide was
fun 12 12 x 10 kids could go up to it
look and had all these Gandhi peaceful
sayings all the way around it and
eventually if we think we need a
brighter light I think that's one of the
things it didn't develop as good as we
like it did develop a little bit but
what we want love doing and I don't have
the picture of it is one day I went in
there with we see who is the with
Christine and we kind of rushed and we
use a little bit of water along the long
patterns with the same with the with the
developing of that image on the thing as
well and after we took it all away you
could actually see Johnny's face so with
that as opposed to keep off the grass my
hope is that you know today and beyond
this that you go and use grass as a way
of expressing yourself as it fit for me
stretching myself here's Fred the camp I
want I can't do this without saying
thanks to credit if you don't know Craig
you'll some of you may have missed
analysis Craig's fellow friend and there
is nothing looks as good as a black and
white dog on a nice greeting grasping a
little bit of anyone so I hope that you
have a wonderful day okay and I know you
will have a lot of people out there like
Danielle and Alex and Craig tomorrow
will be able to answer some of your
questions but one of the things that I
like the most about what this involved
involvement with this has not always
been that you know it's a way of kind of
expressing yourself
artistically which I never knew I had
the ability to do any of that but also
that it's living in sustainable art this
is not the kind of work that has to
damage the environment anyway working
with the environment it's an easy way to
make sustainable art that a lot of
people can enjoy that you don't
necessarily have to go to a museum to
see so my hope is that you have all
those thoughts when you're doing this
work and really I think you're going to
have a wonderful day could be a sticky
hot but as figures after we've been
raining all this time do you have any
questions before I turn it back over to
Marcia what kind of grass on the jewelry
you know I don't really know I think
some of it was moss but most likely it's
ryegrass because it grows so quick it's
pretty almost disposable I mean it grows
on burlap we grow it on your half that's
not I can't say go to grass grass on
yeah grass on burlap right just shoot it
really heavy Morella you we didn't use
peat moss for the comedy thing grass on
burlap burlap has a water hole I mean a
structured a whole lot now they're
different types of burlap did you have a
couple area yeah that's how long
week it's really amazing progress just
pointing out we seated it just because
you think you lay it down evenly and end
up with a few spots so we have to go
back seat a little bit more water in the
middle of winter this green block
prepared did you grow it on the two by
fours or did you tack it on after we
checked it out before you tacked it on
before so it'll ride grasp or hang on a
vertical surface it'll stick it roots
rights of the Berlin sir but how do you
make it stick unusually well we convert
ago no no no well we grow it fly okay
and then we lift it and once it get some
structure to it you mowed it once it
gets from strike and that's why it's one
of these it's critical when you're doing
some of these things it's really
important to mow the grass a little bit
because that encourages you to get dense
it's somewhat counterintuitive but by
clipping it it gets thicker it causes
the grow more laterally as opposed to
groan straight up how long did you
expose it to the overhead projector to
get the was it a week we needed to get
brighter and we needed a brighter light
yep this would be kind of stretch but
the whole idea with green Bruce is there
any way that the grass instead of siding
poshli grow grass on the side of her
house yes yes I mean it won't live
unless you give it one now you can you
know use the you can use warm season
grasses in some places where they won't
need much water but there's no reason to
think you could just get established
good or they can make a matrix structure
of some sort that you could use I mean
they build straw houses straw bale
houses certainly sod roofs are not
unique they've been doing them forever
and the thing that's nice about is you
can actually go up there and sit as
opposed to Adam see them that you can't
touch or it'll die it can be a little
bit functional as well which is what the
idea was at Lincoln Center ya know I
actually think that some that's a
structural it's like gravel which soil
mixed in that they blue grass over the
top up so it infiltrates it yes you do
and they don't work there think so we've
tried that a few times and we haven't
found that it works so good yeah but
it's regressive mean we really have the
data now there's no reason why we can't
have grass partners the trip of grass
parking lots is we think that the trip
seventy percent of a parking lot are the
spaces about thirty percent of the
Traveling things so the traveling lens
will be something other than grass so
we'll make the parking spaces grass and
then what's critical is that you that
you have the spaces on a diagonal
because what we've learned is when you
turn on the grass especially when it's
wet you can pair it so you want to be
able to smoothly go in and park the car
like grant grass growing on graph and we
watered it for a week when we first put
it in and we have done less than nothing
to beep it unless I'm not as quick
done virtually nothing to it and it's
been there we've added out there for
four years have been driving on parking
on for four years how do you pick do
that for your driveway absolutely
without what you know it don't you you
could mow it is their grass it grows and
determine pipe no well yes grass will
grow to a certain height and a flower if
you don't mow it right you'll get these
wispy see dads but you can mow it a
little bit so that it doesn't flour and
some grasses grow very slowly and then
flop over grass that grows on the gravel
no we use tall fescue the same stuff
you're going to Assad your things with
today yeah I'm coming I'm done your
honor you stop this is as easy as it
gets I mean just a little see little
water you got thanks very much hope you
have a clean